[Music]
the concept of linking is foundational
to good rankings and understanding the
Internet at large it starts with the
premise that good content will be cited
by others recommending it to other
people how we cite and recommend
information online is by linking to it
we link to information that we find
valuable based on that the search
engines assess content by how websites
link to one another so we are going to
cover the definition and purpose of
links and the different functions that
links serve we'll also look at how links
mirror human judgment we'll look at how
search engines evaluate links by
mirroring human judgement and how that
affects what's called block level
analysis and how where the location of
different links and how they are used
will greatly affect their relevance
we're going to look at how visitors from
different links sources will behave
differently based on where they came
from and also how you can measure the
effectiveness of links and finally we're
going to look at both good and bad
linking practices the objectives for
this module is for you to understand and
articulate the importance of linking I
want you to be able to describe the
different types of links and their
functions I also want you to be able to
explain why some links are more
important than others and then
understand the concept of block level
analysis and how it applies to both
human searchers and to search engines
and determining relevancy finally I want
you to understand the best practices for
linking to content within your own
website
now links serve a number of purposes
from a functional standpoint they
usually are our primary means of
navigation online we click on links we
go to different pages than from those
pages we find links to other pages links
are also a method of citing other
content when we quote somebody when we
use information that we have found
somewhere else we cite that information
to give credit to the original author
typically online we do that with a link
so that if someone wants to see the
original source document it's available
to them that also helps to provide
credibility to you credibility to the
author of the original source as well as
assigning importance to the knowledge
that came from that original source and
the authority of the original source
links also provide us with a clear
structure of how our websites are built
how the pages relate to one another and
how organized the information can be so
let's break down the functional part of
a link this is important if you're going
to be developing anchor text and linking
to understand the structure the a href
equals is the start of the link tag what
you are doing is developing the
reference of where the document is
contained that's the H ref reference is
what it is short for what comes next
within the quotes is the location of the
document now this can be a full URL or
you may just be linking to a document
that's on the main root level of your
server this is the full location where
you can access the document and so
you're putting the name of the document
the extension so that it will be late
the next part is what I have in caps
you'll notice off to the left I have
something in all blue text and
underlined which most people will
recognize as a link
you see when it is in between the
document location and the closing of the
link tag the text you have in there is
what's called anchor text you see
instead of publishing the document
location and the full URL of the
document we can put the link within text
and create anchor text so all someone
has to do is click on the link and the
document loads for them this anchor text
is vitally important to understanding
how we can add additional relevance to
linking content then we see the closure
of the link tag this is what makes the
internet the internet is millions of
pages connected together by links so
when we look at the functional side of
links and we look at this example here
as you can see the title of this article
is not the URL address of the article
it's a title and the title is the link
that is the anchor text of the link and
so from a search engine standpoint
search engines look to see what words
are being used in the link and how
relevant those words are to the document
that is being linked it also looks to
see where is the link is it in the
editorial information in the article is
it part of the navigation is it in a
sidebar or is it an ad and then also
search engines are looking to see if
this is a text link or an image link how
long has that link been there what type
of link is it does it go somewhere
within your website does it go to
another website or is it a reciprocal
link which I will explain more later
they also look to see the text in the
link and the context of the page with
the link directs you to we utilize links
a little differently
see from a human standpoint whenever we
refer information to another person when
we provide reference material to another
person or even if someone asks us for a
recommendation we provide this
information you see offline we mirror
the same behavior as we do online when
we link people ask us for information
and we provide it we just mirror that
online by making a link offline we
recommend we refer we provide
information to each other in much the
same way the way I want you to think
about it from a human standpoint is that
if you asked another person for advice
or directions or a referral are there
certain people that you would trust more
than others I'm sure the answer to that
is yes and maybe you have some people in
mind that you are thinking about you see
we run across the same issue with search
the search engines know that there are
some websites that are much more
trustworthy than others just like if you
were to ask someone for information I'm
sure you would ask the right person for
the information you would ask the most
knowledgeable trustworthy person
you knew who had authority in that
subject area the search engines are
trying to do the same thing with the
links that we publish on our websites
they're trying to determine who is the
most trustworthy and relevant based on
the recommendations referrals and
citations of other websites to other
websites who are the websites that are
trusted that are authorities the search
engines are trying to do from a
technical algorithmic standpoint what we
do naturally from a human standpoint now
from the human side as I had said before
we need to think of links as information
that we receive from other people
word-of-mouth advice information
directions recommendations this is where
we need to think about links not from
the standpoint
of building false relevance for a search
engine but being a helpful resource for
our readers how can we help them how can
we provide information and how can we be
a credible source of information how can
we develop our authority within the
industry and so that people who have
questions about this content will see
our websites as authoritative and
credible resources the best way to
develop links as you'll see is good
content when people like what they read
when they like what they see
when they are willing to recommend it to
others it's because you have created
something of value and they'll link to
you when they feel that you are credible
and that you are authoritative with this
information only then will they share it
with other people because you have
earned that right for them to share it
with others by providing content that is
informative educational entertaining and
you've provided that service
only then will people then want to
recommend it to others by linking to it
now links serve a number of benefits
when I look at some of the incoming
links to my site one of the things I
notice is that if I get a link in
certain places that can drive a lot of
brand exposure I can have thousands of
people coming to the site looking to see
an article and that provides a lot of
exposure to a lot of people however also
getting a link from a certain website
especially if it's a high relevant
authoritative website I can see my
rankings increase because of that but
then also a good link is going to drive
people that will convert and drive sales
or leads those who become customers so
those are the three aspects of a good
link a good link will drive traffic to
your site
good link will assist your rankings and
a good link will bring in business if
you can get a link to do all three of
those at the same time that's what I
call the golden link because it has all
three benefits usually however you're
going to find that different links will
provide different types of benefits one
of these three or maybe two out of these
three one of the things I'm usually very
focused on is the link that drives sales
or generates leads that's getting links
in the right place that will benefit me
tangibly rather than just getting
thousands of people to see it why it
benefits me financially if I can get a
link in the right place so from here
let's break down the different types of
Link's we have navigational links we see
these in our navigation or primary
navigation maybe the footer of our web
pages where we have links to typical
information such as about us or contact
us we also have sidebar links this might
be related information or offers or
calls to action and then also I would
break it down into outbound or inbound
type of navigation outbound our links
going to other websites inbound links
are links that come from other web sites
and that also I might send to other
pages on my own site now I've used the
term editorial an editorial link is a
link that is found within the content of
the website and by that I mean through
an article so if I am writing an article
and I link to someone else and cite them
or reference them that is what's called
an editorial link it means that it's
part of the content a great example of
this is that the navigation on your web
pages is not part of the content it
serves a function as navigation but it
doesn't have anything to do with
supporting information with citing an
authority so info
and links that you put within the
content and presented content of your
site are considered editorial now
there's also call to action links where
you're bringing someone to a landing
page or a registration page or a sale
page then also we have social links now
these can provide a variety of memes but
typically a social link will go to a
profile maybe it's a username that takes
you somewhere else or comment or maybe
just an image or something that goes to
a social site or that you have placed on
your own site as well either way it's
all contained within that social network
even though the links are going on and
off your site they tend to be controlled
in that social environment now I've used
the term reciprocal link now this is
something very specific a reciprocal
link is one where you would go to
somebody else then you would make a
trade such as if you link to me I'll
link to you and maybe you put those
links on the home page or maybe you
create a page just for that link you see
sometimes it just doesn't make sense and
so the search engines will see that
you've linked to each other but if
there's no contextual relevance if
there's no contextual relevance most
likely you won't get any benefit because
you've agreed to link to each other for
the primary purpose of boosting rankings
now this is not to say that two websites
can't link to each other because there
is some relevance we'll look at some
examples of that later on in this module
also then we have advertising links
these can be ads banners anything on the
page that is an advertising link than if
you were to click on it you would go to
that advertisers page those links are
typically through an ad server and they
take place an entirely different
ecosystem but they are links and we need
to know what kind of links are
advertised
sizing and which kind of links are
functional to our websites now when I
broke down the different types of links
so we have our navigation links we have
links on our sidebar and in our footer
what block level analysis does is that
the search engines look at the code of
the page they break down the page
because it's very easy to figure out
which part of the code has to do with
your navigation which part of the code
has to do with your sidebar in your
footer and which part of the code is
calling ads from an ad server with this
leaves is the editorial content your
article and the ability of search
engines then to break down your page
into these different elements the reason
why they do it is that the links
contained in the editorial space are
considered to be more relevant in terms
of linking to other web sites than any
of the other types of links on your web
page search engines don't consider all
parts of the page to be equally relevant
which is okay because neither do humans
we look at the navigation as utilization
pure utility because it's just helping
me navigate among the different pages of
your website I'm not expecting to learn
anything I'm using it as a functional
means of navigating your site now your
sidebar might have some calls to action
it might have links to other pages but
it's not an article it's what you've
developed and so it might be a little
more important than your navigation but
it's not as important as what you may
have written within content your footer
navigation is basically the same you
control that it's the same on every page
and so what the search engines are
looking for are the unique content the
unique article or information that
you've published and if there is a link
within the editorial content that is
highly relevant because it has to do
with content it has to do with
information that you are sharing and so
the links there are going to be more
highly relevant and are going to be more
important for the search engines to see
it's the same way with humans we're not
going to look at navigation to learn
something it's functional the same thing
with the footer and as humans we're
reading the content that you have in
your article and if you link to another
source
well you've provided us with utility but
it's contextual utility because you're
citing where you found information or
you're citing an additional source or
you are linking to an example and it
enables me as a human to see that
understand it and if I need that
additional information I can click on it
and go to it so I'm going to look at the
information on the page in that article
very differently that I'm going to look
at the headings the navigation the
sidebars or the footer because the
article is what is informing me and so
the links in the article I'm going to
look at very differently and hold them
in a higher level of relevance now over
time search engines have had to refine
the algorithm about links you see in the
early days of search engine algorithms
they used to simply count the amount of
links then if one site had more links
than another that made it more credible
however once people started to figure
that out
people started accumulating links by
really any means necessary and they
would just looking for the sheer volume
of links because they knew if they got
the most amount of Link's it would
affect their rankings and so over the
years the search engines have had to
change and adjust and add more relevance
to their algorithm refine it in order to
look at different aspects of links in
order to properly determine relevance so
over time it wasn't just having a link
it was then also looking at how many
people cite this site as an authority so
looking at the source of the link and
the types of pages then also looking at
the text of the link and matching it
with the text of the page does it match
is it contextual and then looking at the
type of link doing the block
analysis and then also the context the
relevancy of your site compared to the
linking site compared to the link and
the information that's being shared
there also some of the ways that they
can look at it at the age of the link
how long has that link been there humans
do the same thing when we look to see
how long someone has been in business
we're looking at credibility and then of
course there are many many other ongoing
refinements that are going into the
search engines evaluations of links
sometimes the age of the link isn't as
relevant especially when you're looking
for something that has happened very
recently an old link could mean that
it's old news or that something has
changed since then so search engines are
in a constant battle to ensure that
people are not gaming the system by
falsely creating relevance through
linking the link relevancy and the
algorithm is all about trying to
determine who is the most relevant and
credible within this area and that is
the focus of most search engine
algorithm refinements over the past few
years and it will be into the future now
this is where I'm going to start
bringing in some screenshots from a link
management program as a search engine
optimizer a link management program is
probably going to be one of your best
friends as you move along in this
industry in this example this program
link decks that I'm using will track the
incoming links to my website and it'll
also provide a breakdown as to what type
of website those links are coming from
so I can see how many links I have from
blogs how many links I have from news
sites how many links from wiki's how
many links from directories forums
social media public relations sites
articles or additional resources then I
can also add my competitors and I can
compare where I stand in terms of the
amount of links from each source and
where my competitors Stan
in this way I can be sure that we all
have a similar link profile you see if
my linking profile looks vastly
different than all my competitors the
search engines are going to see that as
well and know that something might be
different with me good or bad and that's
going to raise a red flag so I want to
look at the linking profile because
every industry and almost every business
is linking profile it's going to be a
little different but especially among
industries we see that linking profiles
that is the amount of links from
different sources it's going to be
slightly different for every different
type of industry or business so this
else we understand where my links are
coming from which is vitally important
because from a business standpoint one
thing that I've tracked consistently in
analytics is that people will act
differently and also I can predict which
source is going to send me the best
customers you see just because someone
comes from a link doesn't mean they're
going to buy or become a customer or
really become a lead many times they're
going to come look at your information
and leave and based on while they come
to your site whether it's through a blog
a directory a forum or a new site has a
lot to do with how they view your
website and it's all about the context
you see this is what I've learned over
the years is that people will behave
differently based on how they find the
website what I found is that people from
blogs new sites and articles they tend
to stay longer do more and have a higher
chance of conversion of becoming a
customer or a lead the main reason is
because blogs and articles they have a
lot of context it's an article someone
has taken the time to write some
information out and then link to my site
which means there is a highly contextual
reason for someone to click that link
also
it means is that there's a lot less
competition for that link when my link
is in that article
compare that with social news or any
type of social site you see when you're
on a social site you're looking at your
social stream of information there's a
lot of different people competing for
your attention a lot of different things
and it's not just in one subject area
it's usually from multiple subject areas
and so the context is very low because
there's a lot of different types of
information and the competition for your
attention is very high because of that
people from social sites or applications
tend to visit more often
but they only tend to view one page and
leave immediately because they're
looking to see what was interesting and
then they move on to the next subject
that's the difference between how people
react based on where they come from and
so when I'm measuring links I'm looking
to see which links do I have what's the
source and then how do those sources
behave differently from one another and
why you see if I find that I'm getting
links from sources that people are
staying longer
doing more and converting at a higher
rate then I'm going to continue to focus
on building links in those areas because
it directly affects how I monetize my
website
so here's a strategy in building links
one of the things I'm looking at is the
source of links like I said if I can
find a link source that's providing
visitors that will stay look at my
content engage with the content and
eventually convert and convert at a
higher rate than other sources of
content or as visitors then I'm going to
focus on that source and so I'm going to
look at some high authority websites
whether they're industry publications
news sites education sites those are
what are considered high authority blogs
articles news sites that's what I'm
looking to do I want to find the most
authoritative website and sometimes it
happens naturally if people that work at
those websites or manage those sites if
they find you and they like your content
the link to it and that way you can get
more credibility more relevancy certain
people certain organizations certain
websites have more Authority influence
than others it goes back to the question
that I asked you early in this module
that how do you know if someone is more
authoritative than somebody else we also
have meta thority websites which you can
get some links on and low authority
websites which are very easy to get
links but here's what I've learned when
it comes to link building one link from
one high quality website can be worth
hundreds or thousands of mid to low
quality links ultimately it's about
quality not quantity
one of the things that I will do
utilizing my link software is look at
the context of the link I want to see
how relevant this is so as I said if I
want to find a high relevant website
what I'm looking for in terms of this is
I want to see the influence of the
domain as well as the relevance of the
domain those are two factors that we're
going to look at when we're evaluating
the quality of a domain now as I'm
looking at this report here what
influence means is that it is a high
quality website that within the linking
algorithm these sites have a lot of
authority however they may not be
relevant so for example they may have a
lot of sites attributing Authority to
them but they may not be relevant to my
industry which is why we have the next
column of keyword relevance you see when
I'm evaluating my links I'm looking for
the sources that are both influential
and relevant that means that I've got a
link from a site that fits the two
standards of high authority its
authoritative and relevant now it's good
to have links from authoritative sites
that might not be relevant it's still
authoritative however to get the full
benefit I want it to be influential and
relevant but not to say that I'm not
looking for links from these other
sources this is just a means of
measuring what you have as well as
comparing it to your competitors and
other websites
now here's some best practices when I'm
optimizing anchor text I want to
maintain contextual relevance so I want
to use text in the text link and I want
to explain to people what they're
linking to what they're going to find
when they click on that link if I use an
image as a link I'm going to use an alt
attribute because of that image doesn't
show up that Ultra Butte is necessary to
let people know where to go but also I
do get a little tiny bit of benefit by
using that alt attribute within the
image link I also want to look at the
relevance of the source page that I'm
linking to and make sure contextually
the link the link text and the content
of the page is contextually relevant to
the destination page I also want to be
sure that I don't overuse the keywords
that I don't make multiple links to the
same destination that I don't use the
same anchor text over and over I can be
downgraded or even penalized by the
search engine algorithm if that is found
on my pages so as an example instead of
using click here for a how-to article I
might use the exact phrase of how to fix
whatever it is and use that as the link
to the page that has the content that's
a simple way of looking at anchor text
am i directing someone to additional
information if I am then how can I
present it to them so they know exactly
what they're going to find and link it
appropriately I look at as developing
the next step for your readers where do
you want them to go what do you want
them to do what resources do you have
available to them
how can you structure them so that
they're easily understood and you're
explaining the final destination
like I said if you overuse anchor text
you can be downgraded or penalized by
the search engines so what I will tell
you to do is number one
avoid overstuffing anchor content that
means needlessly repeating keywords in
the anchor text don't do that
avoid being redundant meaning don't have
four or five or six links with the same
anchor text going to the same page
that's a clear way of letting search
engines know that you're going overboard
don't just randomly place links
throughout your text just to get the
link ask yourself are you really helping
the reader find the information they
need and do it once and then also avoid
extremely overly promotional words
within the link text such as best expert
cheap number one those types of things
so a couple examples we can say for
travel advice click here but I would say
here is my travel advice and link travel
advice rewrite it be creative if it were
easy everyone would be doing it but this
is where you can write things in a
better way to get the attention of the
reader and position it as a resource
also utilizing your URL as the link air
as the anchor text as well for the link
in order to get that click as I've got
it here I would not recommend that you
use that I would recommend that you
avoid that also the third line to check
out the best website for iPhones and
iPhone accessories utilizing overly
promotional words is one of those ways
that you can easily get caught by the
search engines
now for future considerations when it
comes to links realize that the majority
of algorithm changes are link based
evaluation refinements because people
are constantly attempting to fool the
search engines and develop a false link
profile you should work to create high
quality links with high quality content
i wouldn't chase after poor or low
quality links now as i've mentioned
before there are a number of tools
available for you to manage and measure
your backlinks tools such as link dex
Moz Ravin advanced link manager majestic
SEO and then also you can use your
google analytics as well however Google
Analytics only shows you the visitors
that have come from links and what
they've done the basic functions of link
management software and there are many
other types other than what are listed
here
but the first thing that it does is just
provide a catalog of incoming links from
other domains to your site and your
competitor sites they offer tools for
comparison to see which domains are
linking to you what type of link it is
and on which pages those links are
listed
they'll also report newly acquired links
in the past 30 60 90 days or something
similar to that the purpose of link
management software is to help you
assess high quality domains versus low
quality domains in terms of importance
and relevance like I said the first job
of a link management tool is to collect
all of your backlinks you add your
domain and the tools will usually spider
the domain they'll go out into search
engines and go out into many other
formats in order to find and retrace who
is linking to you what page that link is
contained
sometimes what text is on that page and
what text is being used in the link they
will catalog all of your incoming links
organize them format them and report
back to you
most of these linked programs provide
additional filters and management tools
so that you can get more insights about
who is linking to you how they are
linking to you and the type of site
personally I use link decks in order to
monitor and report on my backlinking so
the first report here that I'm showing
out of link decks is that I see the
total amount of incoming links to my
domain this says I have over 2,000 links
and those 2,000 links are on about 1,000
domains on average it looks like I have
about two links from every domain that
is linking to me so this is one way that
you start to look at your links number
one the total amount of domains that are
linking to you and then the total amount
of links available this way you can
isolate domains that are linking to you
consistently and also find those that
may not be the best domains or that are
sending a lot of links that are just not
relevant the next thing I do in
analyzing my links is to look at the
type of link meaning the type of site
that it's coming from this report breaks
down the amount of links coming from
blogs news sites directories forums
social sites articles or resources now
it doesn't usually get all of those
links but it does get enough to give you
an idea of how well you're doing
any channel one of the things that I do
like about this report is it also has a
timeline so I can look and see when new
links have been acquired and maybe when
some links have been just disappeared
that's called churn and it's normal it's
normal because many times a link is
published on social media and it kind of
just goes away or it's not tracked
anymore by your link management software
it can't find it anymore and so linking
is always dynamic you are always gaining
new links and losing old links there's
going to be a normal amount of churn
the next report shows me all of the
domains that are linking to me it also
shows me in the next column how many of
those domains are also linking to at
least one competitor and it will list as
many competitors if I have listed in
here if they list to multiple
competitors it will let me know the
influence of that site or the authority
that site is seen because of the amount
of websites and credibility that
Authority has for that domain it'll also
let me know the keyword relevance how
relevant that website is overall
contextually to my domain and the
content that I have it will also let me
know how many pages on that domain have
links to my website so I can also go
through and I can filter this list by
the type of site I can filter by those
domains that are using anchor text to
see how much anchor text is being used
and what type of anchor text there are
many different ways that you can filter
through all of the domains that are
linking to you in order to get an idea
of what's happening on your domain what
are competitors doing and also the
relevance of those links to your site
now when I say that I can add
competitors this is another type of
report very similar to the one I showed
earlier where I look at my own standing
in the different types of sources of
links such as blogs directories forums
and so on
I can also when I add my competitors
look to see how they are performing in
those different areas as well and so I
can compare my link profile to my
competitors different industries are
going to have different backlink
profiles they might be more heavily
weighted towards blogs or they might be
more heavily weighted towards forums or
social sites in this way I can look to
see if my competitors are actively link
building and how they're going about it
I can see where maybe they are excelling
in one area that the rest of the
competitors are not so I can compare
different strategies I can also compare
different timelines to
see if I am acquiring links at a faster
rate than my competitors this is very
important if you are a newer business or
a newer website trying to compete now
specifically what I can do is look at an
individual domain in this case this
domain has three pages linking to me and
that domain also links to two of my
competitors I can look at the specific
pages and what I'm looking at here are
snippets this should be familiar to you
because what it's showing is the URL of
the page that's linking to my page it
shows me the page title of that page and
then in this report it lets me know if
there are any keywords being used in the
link in the anchor text as well as the
number of links from that page now what
this tells me is that this is most
likely a directory something that is
listing all the different places that
where you can buy products because it's
most likely linking to the domain name
seeing that there are no keywords being
used in anchor text and also that there
are 16 outbound links from that page
that means that it must be a list of
some sort and they are linking not only
to me but most likely to competitors as
well so I can track my links at the
domain level and at the page level I can
look to see which pages might have more
influence or relevance to my content I
can also see the link URL the page title
if any keywords are being used in the
anchor text and also within the context
of how many additional links are leaving
from that page if there are a high
amount of outgoing links on that page
then a link from that page might not be
as valuable since there are so many
links the less links there are coming
out from that page the more it will
benefit my site because I'm getting more
benefit from less links
now also what I'm going to do is compare
the link reports to my analytics I'm
going to go to my analytics because
linking software does not show traffic
it doesn't show how many people are
clicking on the link it only shows who's
linking to you but it does not show
visitor activity analytics will show you
visitor activity to see which domains
are most effective in sending visitors
to your site you'll go back to the
primary benefits of linking visitors
branding and business analytics show me
visitors and business it shows me which
domains are sending me visitors and
which of those visitors are becoming
customers so what I can do is go to
google analytics look at all the domains
that are referring traffic to my site I
can also click on the domain and see the
destination page that they are linking
to I can see how many visitors are
coming either monthly or annually how
often they're coming back whether
they're new users or repeat users how
long they stay how many pages they view
and how many conversions as a result of
those visits this is a great way to get
a 360-degree view of your linking
because not only do you want links that
will help you rank better you also want
links that will send business and
customers to you as well building links
can take many forms ideally it is
through networks relationships and
marketing that other websites and users
learn about you like you and recommend
you to others unfortunately there is a
lot of bad outdated and untrustworthy
advice to be found about building links
to your website in this section I'll
present the best practices as accepted
by the OU MCP standard
the objectives for this module that
you'll be able to develop a link
building strategy that you'll understand
the value of different link types
finally you'll be able to find inbound
link opportunities the first step in
building links is to evaluate what you
have now there are many tools available
that you can utilize to do this for you
there are automated tools that you can
get that will catalog all of the
incoming links to your website some of
them are link decks Maas Raven or
advance link manager there are many that
can do that you may also want to utilize
your analytics as well in order to find
websites that link to you the first step
is evaluating where you are right now
your incoming links have a significant
impact on your rankings and you can do a
lot of on-page optimization and see some
results however a lot of Google's
algorithm takes into account links from
other high quality websites now when you
evaluate what you have in this example
I'm showing you a screenshot from link
decks link decks catalogs the incoming
links to my website and it groups them
into different areas the first way it
groups them is by high value or high
influence domains those are websites
that link to me that have a lot of
influence not necessarily in my industry
but high influence based on the amount
of people that link to them as an
authority on many different subjects the
next way that it groups that is based on
relevance now this is when it looks at
the match of my content versus the
content of the other website in the
first example we can see the National
Library of Medicine
it is a high influence website because
it is a government website with a lot of
information that is cited frequently
because of the amount of other websites
linking to that site it has a high
amount of influence now based on the
website that I am measuring there is a
lot of keyword relevance meaning that
that National Library of Medicine site
with the government has a lot of content
that's very similar to my site a lot of
the same keywords are being used so not
only is this website of high influence
it also has a lot of relevance and
that's key when evaluating my backlinks
I want to look at which websites are
also referring traffic so while I may
have a link from the National Library of
Medicine I want to look at my analytics
and look to see is it also providing
visitors our visitors following that
link to my site and I also want to look
at the quality of traffic that it
produces do these visitors stay longer
than average do they convert more than
average I want to look at the quality of
traffic based on the source next I want
to look at the incoming links from those
other websites number one I want to make
sure that the incoming link from the
other site is both accurate and relevant
meaning the text that is used in the
link is it accurate to the content that
will appear on the page when the visitor
clicks that link is the content relevant
this is especially relevant if I have
updated my website changed the content
or moved things around I want to be sure
that that incoming link sends visitors
to the appropriate page and the
appropriate information I also want to
ensure that that link is worded
correctly that it uses the right words
that is sending visitors and setting
expectations of the content that they
will see I may need to contact the web
site manager or owner and maybe ask for
a better link text or a more accurate
page destination now this requires some
interaction with the owner or manager of
another website and you always want to
be respectful of their time and not
demanding that they make any changes in
some cases the organization may be so
big you may never find the right person
in order to optimize the text or the
destination of that link you always want
to look for accuracy in cases where your
company or website name is utilized in
the link but also if there is any
contact information such as address
phone number a description of your
business and any Content make sure it's
accurate and at all points to the right
place another way to look for links is
to simply go to a search engine and
start doing searches search for your
company your business your company name
and look for websites that may mention
you but do not have a live link to your
website many times your company will be
mentioned or cited but there will not be
a live link you can only find these
through doing searches and seeing which
websites mention you without linking to
you now this could be an opportunity to
get an easy link especially if you can
find some contact information and
finding the right person that could add
a link to your company information again
you'll need to be polite ask for their
help and it will help it if you can
develop the link along with the link
text and send that over giving them just
a quick and easy edit to be able to add
the information so make it as easy as
possible as an example I've provided a
sample request format again you want to
be polite you want to be inviting and
respectful of their time and their
management sometimes like I said you may
find the right person that can help you
however the larger the company the more
difficult it will be to make this happen
this just requires your patience and
again being polite and not expecting the
company to do what you are asking many
times this is just a formality and
sometimes companies will act on it so be
sure to approach this with the right
expectations the next thing I want to
look at our business listings these are
the easy ways to establish links and
ensure that links are where they should
be and also opportunities look for
business directories especially if your
company has a local presence you can
utilize Chamber of Commerce lists
Association lists or local listings if
they are on websites see if they offer
links that can go to your website rather
than just the list of businesses that
are in the area even on a larger level
you can look for associations
directories or listings where you can
add your business or double-check if
your business is there and always ensure
that your business name address phone
number and URL are correct complete and
consistent with other listings the next
level will require some active marketing
and that's where you search for
opportunities you can go out and look
for other resource lists within your
industry or directories of businesses
within your industry and you can get a
link many times through membership or
submitting your business as a resource
however you may want to step up your
marketing you can do that by
interviewing your clients
seeing if they might be willing to
provide a testimonial and a link to your
website you may also want to go out and
find other communities online maybe some
social communities that are relevant to
your industry get involved with those
communities fill out a profile and get
involved by contributing information by
sharing information you'll find that
people like getting information and
they'll respond by linking to your site
another option is to utilize the tool
that you had for indexing your links
from the first step you can also add
your competitors and you can look at
their backlinks you can look and see
which websites and which domains are
linking to your competitors but you
always need to go and see why what are
those other sites linking to and what is
the nature of that link sometimes it
makes clewd you from being able to
approach competitors backlinks and ask
them for links however if they're being
linked to by companies that are simply
stating here are vendors in this space
and they are linking your competitors
and you're not there then it might make
a lot of sense for you to approach and
ask if you can be listed as well however
be sure that the links to your
competitors are not from a consumer or
customer relationship in that case it
might be out of line for you to ask for
a link make sure if you approach anyone
who is linking to a competitor and
asking for a link to your site make sure
the context is right and then it makes
sense for them and that's the ultimate
judge of value does it benefit somebody
else to link to your site we all know
that it will benefit you but when you
present your link request you need to
offer value and the benefit for others
to link to you so be sure that you
present it in a way that is beneficial
and good for those be
well that will be adding the link
they're the ones that have to take the
work to do it and they're also the ones
that are adding a recommendation for you
and your business so as always you need
to be considerate and patient now the
best way to build links is by creating
something that people like and sharing
it you see the best way to build links
is by creating value through content or
information or entertainment you see
when people like things they link to it
if they find a study or a white paper or
research that you performed they link to
it if you post a infographic that
explains something and it's attractive
people link to it you see that's what's
most amazing about linking I find that
when we put most of our effort into
creating content that people like that's
what builds the most valuable and the
most relevant links and so what type of
content well you can create infographics
videos top 10 lists or articles articles
with advice or analysis of market data
or even research that type of content
people love it and so when you publish
it out you utilize social media to
extend the reach and the visibility of
that type of content and when someone
likes it the link to it and recommend it
to others now people also like depending
upon your industry or your business they
also like some personality maybe some
humor people always like expert
information they like the cute this is
why pictures of cats tend to be liked
and linked to more than almost anything
else
and also the unexpected if you can
inject any of that into your content
that just makes it more valuable more
personable and again more shareable by
other people and if
times someone shares it it builds a link
to your site you see the best linking is
when people like something when you
create something that people like and
share you might be surprised at the many
opportunities there are to get links
based on your content I've seen many
many blogs based on cooking fashion art
sports music and when people specialize
within a specific topic they always find
an audience and so anything they publish
builds links even on certain social
media sites such as Pinterest people
upload pictures on articles and
infographics especially about
landscaping flowers food cars you name
it there is a special interest for
anything and you can develop links from
those social sites to your site and it
can generate traffic even with a blog
developing articles that talk about
upcoming events new music sports
whatever it is when you create content
that people like it takes the longest
amount of time to build content for
building links when you develop your own
content that's the biggest investment
you'll make in time and research and
writing and presentation however the
result is that when you develop that
content you will receive the best and
highest quality links and the most
valuable links are going to be to that
content
mentioned before one high-quality link
can be worth more than hundreds or
thousands of low-quality links so my
best advice is to create content people
like that they link to and that will be
high-value links that you'll generate to
your site hey once you become an expert
in digital marketing then subscribe to
the simple learn Channel and click here
to watch more such videos turn up and
get certified in digital marketing click
here